hello and welcome to this video planters
master oh gee pop no name so what is 40
pop up to so we get a Sicilian and oh
not one of the lines I know particularly
well I know that this is something I
come into action is what they play okay
yeah okay not not ideal then not ideal
can i it's it's a bit slow but let's
prevent b5 probably this is not the
critical line let's see hmm ok I
understand the e5 square but still the
queen is like right there to pressure
only six
I will definitely take g6 Sanders in
this position not six yes but ok we will
not take it anyway so I might as well
double or is he playing Knight to g4
okay ticking you first and now go from
here
who did this lets you force them all
right but I mean they have quite quite
some some stuff here
so look here he's taking age 6 I mean
okay I would like I would would prefer
to have this Bishop but I'm writing his
king or is there something else already
here's something directly tactical
probably not it has to take on age 60
you say anything else no yeah I'm not
happy about giving up the dark squared
Bishop here but I mean the f file that
should be there should be some danger
than alpha black those pieces don't do
anything though this is a big problem
but how to do it you cannot move the
bishop Rick f8 is something that that is
actually not one is agenda rook edge for
no and 94 years quinta c5
look a fate is the problem here people
he will trade okay at the end i can take
a six actually hmm
okay hey drew gave eight anyway I came
later in the night around I'm spending
too much time I can take with the bishop
actually and now I can take a six not
that it is so fantastic but maybe not g4
is just killing me now is just a thing
of it cat and if this could be easily
winning lat you for now where I was a
really naive game by white a naive what
I mean hmm probably ashram the low him
to take that page 6 h-6 yeah so this is
winning huh
time warning
yep everything winds here for him clock
cannot do much 9f 294 whatever it wins
and that was bad I mean what why did i
squatted I screwed up top it felt
reasonably dangerous ha ok white resigns
I don't really believe that this is that
even if he has to go back that this can
be all that great ok unsurprisingly I'm
winning here somehow let's switch it on
so Bishop g5 clean edge voice is better
ok and this was bad ok and that's it
let's it's a slow IE mostly I come on I
cannot stand we have a guy moving yeah
whatever so so this this was strong and
Bishop g5 back and the night doesn't
have many squares and if it moves i have
probably and I can take actually of
course I can take there is this pressure
yeah and that looks pretty good so that
was the way to do it and here I'm
already it's already not good yet it's a
very fine line I mean equal but should
be true
to cut a g4 here of course yeah of
course this is the proof good
prophylactic move I just discover g4 and
then we'll get one yeah of course and
once you see against it's not that
difficult just just prevent that you
form a difficult position public that
the stock wish wants to play wants to
play this yeah this is nice for wider
it's a dangerous dangerous attack and
what he says here I don't understand he
you're writing me strange messages ok so
here yeah and 10 this is not look at
seven wins oh my god that wasn't so
difficult cap and e5 winning I me know
at least the draw I mean I can find a
draw at least cap so that killed but
that that's pretty cool right 'if I've
that is a win you cannot prevent Bishop
g6 Queen f7 okay
yeah no 92 in that that sets nonsensical
I had compared to look at seven ha ha
yet young I'm getting killed yeah look
up seven whom I didn't think about the
move I mean he of course does not have
to lose that that's pretty clear this
should be seven assists the engine
suggestion and the den broek f7 is a
draw which I probably have to have to
measure happened ha what if I will
probably be taught not ending where I am
no yes no yes looking there's no squares
has to give me the Queen and that was
interesting so gave several hmm I should
at least consider this move I mean not
seeing the Wright continuation is one
thing but I saw the ideas some at some
at some position i saw the idea but not
in this one but there is it if i would
have seen it i probably would have
played it okay thanks for watching